نعم نعم
الأخت الكبرى
لن يكون للأبد لماذا هنا ثم في
خدش
ماذا او ما
كوب C1
القيادة هي سام والعكس صحيح
عدت معي
تحت
أهل الحب يقتلون الغرض
بغرض
ما يوتيوب
الخاص بي
فى غاية الحزن
يخرج يعني في
هذه
واحد
الأشخاص
لن تصدق
حسنا اذن
ايضا
هل هذا هو ما أنت عليه
لا شيئ
لأنه كذلك
إذن ما الذي ستهتم به سوني؟
نعم
[موسيقى]
عطلة نهاية الاسبوع
مرتبة
كم هو بالفعل جدا
هو - هي
سابقا
بلا قلب
لذلك هذا واحد يذهب
حقيبة
اذهب إلى النوم
دائما في المنزل
لأموال ماري الإيطالية
ما الفيلم خلال المهرجان؟
أنا
أنا آسف لكل من سكانك
رؤية المهد للاستيقاظ حقا حتى الامتحان
سأتركها تقرر ، فهي لا تعرف أنها ستفعل
كيف هذا
الآن سوف تضطر إلى
تحدث
على الاصح
يجب أن تكون هنا الطبقة الأم
تعال من هذه الأرض لست باردا
هذه
ثمين
الأول الربع الثاني
[موسيقى]
نعم
اخو الام
[موسيقى]
إرادة
اظهار
قال لي
ايضا
تبذل قصارى جهدك للحصول على القليل
الأخ الأكبر
[موسيقى]
تفضل ، ها هي حقًا جميلة جدًا
ال
[موسيقى]
حقيقي
السيد لينه
ونعم
هذا نحن
[موسيقى]
استمر
شقيق
ماذا تريد ان تحصل؟
المزيد حول هذا الموضوع ببطء
الغفران
لها كلمة سهلة Sy
انظر
حسنًا ، أنا وأمي نعرف بالفعل
انا اقول هذا
ان نكون
هو ذا
اذا تعال
لا أعلم
هل هناك مرة أخرى
هنا نعم
طريق
معالجة
هذا شيء جيد للحصول على شهادة
يطلب جسدي شفقة رقيقة
بمجرد أن تشعر بالألم ، استخدم Ok هذا كل شيء
ستخرج الرسالة ثم الشركة و
يجب أن يقف على
اشخاص
سوف يحتفظ بها مع الرجل الذي لديه بالفعل
علبة
ان نكون
هذا هو المقطع يأتي الناس
طوال حياتي أزهر النجاح
يوم توم
21 شهرًا ستكون دورتك الشهرية نعم
اسم شيئا؟
[موسيقى]
لكن ذلك
نرى
[موسيقى]
قليلا
هل هذا مقبول
[موسيقى]
امسك بي
اذهب للأعلى
علي أن أفكر مرة أخرى
نعم نعم